sans labro il était garçon coiffeur très
exemplaire angoulême en est fier voici
la carrière du héros de romer le
meilleur dans le rôle de l'acteur
luchini alias fabrice del dongo intello
rigolo plus anti portrait chinois
fabrice luchini bonsoir j'ai été connu
avec les nuits de la pleine lune de
robert ta première expérience théâtrale
c'était le veilleur de nuit titre il
était devenu une star sur scène en
jouant le voyage au bout de la nuit
d'après céline arsaut naturel que tu
sois vite et dans une histoire produits
blanchissants conviendra
alors tu as été viré de l'école à 13 ans
et demi pourquoi
t'es fait quoi
non rien de
rien de
tout simplement parce qu'à cette
époque-là on allait à l'école jusqu'à 14
ans
donc on a tout à fait juste six mois
d'avancé parce que je suis du mois de
novembre
j'espère ça fait des études normales
après tu as été apprenti coiffeur
j'étais un peu tu voulais devenir
coiffeur
pas du tout c'est ça pour quoi
on n'avait pas de pignons va je veux
dire on n'avait pas cette époque-là des
opinions sur nos destinées social ma
mère et mon père ont fait le maximum
pour que j'aille à l'école longtemps ils
ont tout de suite vu que c'était pas
peut-être là où je donnais donc dense
dans leur truc à eux c'est que quand on
n'est pas bon à l'école on va travailler
ouais et toi c'était la coiffure c'était
le comme je n'étais pas assez fort pour
être dans l'alimentation ou dans des
commerces comme eux du grossiste en
poissons et 12 ans ils ont dû réfléchir
et se dire que peut-être le métier de
coiffeur était plus à hemani répété fin
elle va mal je ne sais pas si j'étais
maniéré en tout cas je n'étais pas apte
à porter les cageots et était en même
temps de déjeuner non et je suis très
nourris fondé et structurée par là le
rythm and blues mais je parle du vrai
c'est à dire tout ce qu'a commencé avec
wilson pickett cndf en milliards de
collisions formidable la connaissent un
formidable volume 1 2 et puis des gens
très très très très connus comme jean
washington alors un jour dans un café ça
c'est quand même la légende de fabrice
luchini un jour dans un café tu vois
rentrée à typer tu lui dis vous avez des
weston à 380 francs et vous avez des
talons de quatre centimètres et demi
d'eau et vous les cirés en dessous comme
victorio de sicav ce qui vous permet de
pouvoir regarder la mèche et vérifier
parce que les gens étaient tellement
obsédés des chaussures il y avait un tel
ou tel mystique de la religion des
chaussures à cette époque là les weston
et cherche les lobes les loques du temps
du faubourg saint-honoré palais loeb qui
ont été rachetés par hermès le temps des
lobes le mec vous recevez avec un
tablier de cuir jusqu'aux pieds et qui
faisait des choses se rend peu au foot
autruches qui vous
qui vous regardez la largeur du pied la
manière dont ils progressaient c'est
vrai que j'avais 7 ans et j'étais
fasciné et gérant j'ai vu monsieur
philippe labro qui avait déchargé qui a
été sidéré que j'ai pu définir les
décharges sauvages quand il avait des
chais twin avec des trous des consuls ça
fait quand même 25 ans est très vive
longtemps alors il t'a pris tout de
suite dans un film logiciels payants en
verlan et il m'a demandé de refaire un
nom après la même situation il filme ça
fait tout peut arriver ce qui est quand
même là aussi un signe effectivement
elle a aussi des maths est devenu
l'interprète favori de rumeurs c'est un
peu comme ça que les gens te connais
santa fe trois films avec rohmer donc
temps a fait 3 avec tout le mal et tu as
même fait un film avec aldo maccione à
vous êtes fiancée d'aldo maccione celui
qui s'appelait tu es folle bois est faux
et malgré tout a quand même une image
intello tu as une image d'acteur intello
c'est bizarre important vu donner du mal
pour faire défini par lots comment ça se
fait à ton avis pas tu dis même que
c'est contradictoire parce qu en fait un
acteur c'est un paquet d'émotion et un
acteur intello c'est contradictoire ben
c'est à dire qu'on peut pas être un
atelier peut pas être un acteur intello
ouais ça me semble les hameçons embêtant
parce qu'un acteur ça peut pas penser ni
réfléchir au moment où il exécute donc
il peut faire ce qu'il veut avant ou
après l'essentiel c'est qu'il soit
efficace et qui communiquent qui
nourrissent qui servent les auteurs dont
on lui donne la responsabilité qui
trahissent pas qui serve de sa pensée
peut-être à un moment mais qui à un
moment ou un autre la met de côté face
avec qui peut mais certainement pas avec
la pensée uniquement leur théâtre bon
il ya un truc qui est exceptionnel c'est
monologue d'une heure que tu as tiré du
voyage au bout de la nuit je t'en
souviens là comme ça
la chaîne a gelé cette année là je suis
né en mai c'est moi le printemps
alors quand ils rient ou quand on
frissonne à ce moment là c'est bon on va
passer une heure et quart agréable si là
il se passe rien c'est un peu délicat
mais après on peut rattraper par la
suite quand le public par exemple que je
rencontrais qui était un peu heurtée par
l'aspect un tout petit peu raide du
début du spectacle je greffet cette
phrase qu'on connaît tous ceux de céline
dit en parlant de des relations
amoureuses il dit l'amour chez les
hommes c'est l'infini à la portée des
caniches tu vois mon briquet là oui
merci alors tu fais un truc qui va
sortir sur sur antenne 2 qui s'appelle
six crimes sans assassins de bernard
stora adapté par berroyer stora
d'ailleurs tu fais quoi là dedans japhet
un gars qui est payé pour faire un livre
sur un grand connaisseur des
commissaires et marielle
et marielle donc suivis par ceux
monsieur qui va être à la fois le
narrateur réacteurs
son chroniqueur chronique et sans jouer
ville
c'est bien parce extra ça c'est
formidablement assez
il a dit que c'était un allumé il l'a
dit de marielle aussi ah bon c'est un
compliment
oui quand on travaille beaucoup c'est
pas un compliment au début mais tout ce
qui est tout ce qui tout ce qui au début
et si on peut dire un truc ça pas grand
intérêt mais si on peut dire un truc
c'est que tout ce qui au début forme ton
caractère qui est un peu un handicap
pour fonctionner il pourrait être aimé
désiré et par la profession et par le
public peut devenir quand il est poli
travail et ce
quand il est en est pas con sommation
pour que les gens viennent regarder
c'est ça qui fait après ta
caractéristiques donc allumé au début
c'est drôle de défaut quand la
singularité est acceptée elle devient
rentable
attendez là depuis longtemps n'ont pas
de file donc à bord maintenant depuis
les nuits de la pleine lune et y laisser
quelques pièces de théâtre que j'ai
joués
je peux être que
drôlement vous le verset par la chance
que j'ai de travail et de choisir des
rôles que je veux faire mais évidemment
c'est pas marrant la condition d'acteurs
ceci étant dit genre je trouve ça
formidable peut pas avoir à choisir
quand tu choisis c'est plus difficile
mais j'ai toujours une pudeur effrayant
c'est là
l'impudeur avec laquelle les gens se
raconte alors que leur leur
individualité leur petit d'existence et
pas très intéressante et un acteur né
fréquentable quand il vient témoigner de
quelqu'un d'autre en l'occurrence soit
célina grand écrivain soit molière soit
qui triment mais sa petite existence
balmer disait ça paye on force les en
force on demande aux acteurs de penser
d'ailleurs c'est vous pas vous mais les
journalistes qui demande aux gens de
port aux eaux propres acteurs de pense y
pense pas vraiment chaudes sont très
plongeant leurs avis sur tout ils sont
proches de toi tu entres dans des
invitations des ambiguïtés d'anormalité
tabac navy t il sans rien ils n'ont rien
d'exceptionnel heureusement mais on leur
demande alors c'est très drôle parce que
les journalistes vous dise vous force à
réfléchir alors qui
r j'avais pas pensé est-ce que je suis
un acteur avec la libye qui met à
réfléchir alors que qu'est ce que tu
fais est une énergie qui essayent de
d'apprendre un métier parce que tu peux
pas vivre son métier pour te dis mon
idéal c'est de rester en famille
regardez sébastien à la télé duras
l'avait dit pour eux pourra nous il ya
quelque chose de très étrange qui
dépasse la réaction snob et culturelle
sur les grands présentateurs qui dès qui
a incarné qu'ils sont dépositaires d'une
humanité moi j'ai dit à un moment quand
je regardais le monsieur de vous parler
qu'il était bouddhique il était
bouddhique dans le sens qu'il n'y avait
plus de jugement sur lui même il était
dans l' dans l'abandon de sa vérité et
franchement vous le voulez le frigo et
je me dis que c'est pas possible que ça
ne soit que ça si c'est que ça c'est
pathétique mais ce n'est pas que ça il
incarne ça fait du bien il appelle joli
pactole table toutes les semaines mais
je crois qu'il ya quelque chose à
trouver là dedans aussi il apaise il est
bon et je crois que c'est sexuel la
manière dont il tient le micro il a une
espèce de dispositions apportées le
micro à la fois à la peine les ja ce qui
lui est réservé aux tic lui il aborde
l'érotisme avec une une pudeur française
a fait un petit jeu tous les deux
étaient prêtes à un an si proche n'a
[Musique]
une injure
quand je voudrais être qu elle un jour
tu serais
[Musique]
j'essayais d'en trouver non parce qu'à
un moment il disait la mère deviner dans
sa vie cette capacité à jouir à des
profondeurs inoubliable de jouir comme
un continent mais alors une insulte que
j'aimerais ça va d'accord la phrase est
plus belle une maladie que je voudrais
être c'était très très lente est une
maladie très très lente mais très
périphérique ont pas un truc qui soigne
à l'homéopathie
ou d'infirmité une infirmité
j'avais un ami décadent qui trouvait
qu'un vague pied go était extrêmement
séduisant bah oui moi je te répète parce
que d'affirmer series a annoncé ça
[Musique]
au
bal aura un rôle à tous et du livre de
dostoïevski il raconte que c'est la
thèse de nietzsche effrayante dit que
dans l'est dans les bagnes il ya les
plus belles nature humaine celle qu'on
était complètement opposés à la
civilisation et qui ont encore manifesté
un instinct tout ça prend des
précautions une perversion
[Musique]
lesbienne tellement c'était un supplice
mais tu ne trouble totalement relancé
sans entendu si j'étais un supplice ce
jeu je suis absolument incapable de
répondre et si c'était une cicatrice
à battre le le dépositaire du langage du
poète pas ce que je vais dire si vous
croyez que les mots sont des mots sur
une page écrite qu'on comprenait donc
rien les mots sont la cicatrice qui paye
j'accueille maintenant fabrice luchini
ah
oui vous vous mettez là ouais fabrice
luchini bonsoir je vous ai préparé un
petit jingle pour vous bien
les tapis en art 10 ans est très sympa
ça j'apprécie beaucoup vous un peu du
noir comme alors fabrice luchini vous
avez déclaré le pire c'est évidemment la
télévision elle peut rendre antipathique
alors qu'on a tout simplement le trac
mais quand on a tourné un film il faut
bien les défendre alors l'occurrence est
en l'occurrence un spectacle vous avez
le trac vous à la télé mais
oui bien sûr on peut dire un gros carré
ouais j'ai fait une ou deux émissions
avec fabrice et j'ai un peu eu une ou
deux émissions je sais un peu comment il
fonctionne c'est qu'il arrive toujours
tout timide et ré où il ya un mot puis
un deuxième et à la fin il rachète la
production qui parle et il va chanter
adamo dans cinq minutes alors
c'est une collaboration délicate pour
vous parce que ce qui aurait pu se
passer quand était pavoisé déjà
et
déjà menacé
avocats étaient pas mal parce que ça
fait une émission tu es c'est un
tu vas venir adamo quand même elle a
maintenant que c'est vendu comme ça je
suis maroc mais si haut si moi j'avais
sur moi je demande de l'accent pieds
noirs moi je suis d'abord très très
heureux d'abord avant tout d'être avec
d'être près de vous qui avait fait un
film immense je le redis didier grand
film
n'essayez pas de m'embrouiller
alors allez-y
donc fabrice luchini vous reprenez à
partir du 4 décembre de spectacles au
théâtre de la madeleine oui un but un
véritable succès populaire combien de
gens sont venus déjà le voit et ça fait
450 ou 500 présentations ça doit faire
deux cent mille personnes deux cent
mille personnes et là c'est déjà il
paraît enfin sceller les patrons du
théâtre de la madeleine qui disent ça
c'est que les gens quand ils ont su que
ça allait commencer ils ont déjà
téléphoner pour réserver avant même
qu'ils aient de la promotion ou qu'ils
aient des affiches dans paris c'est vrai
oui un peu un petit peu un petit peu
vrai c'est pas cher à ces sons deux
premières places sont à 100 francs
wimille et cher sont à 2 102 110
à 210 on vous entend être sang-froid
on vous voit
les moyennement cher et sont
quand vous dites des textes d'hugo de
baudelaire de nietzsche de la fontaine
de céline on peux nous en dire un petit
bout céline dion avec
non pas tout de suite donc je pense que
ça va se détendre il ya pas d'étendre
notre ami
non mais choquant plus en général c'est
quelqu'un qui est ici des citations à un
moment précis dans un contexte
particulier que parfois on lui a
reproché ce soit de la pédanterie qu'en
fait je pense que c'est plus une forme
d'humilité et que quand les autres quand
on n'est pas content on peut pas trouver
les mots pour le dire et quand d'autres
personnes vont très bien dit je trouve
que c'est l'ambiance se détend et elle
s'élève surtout a donc c'est dire que
quand même grâce à ça vous mademoiselle
comme toujours souvent à part les
artistes véritable écart les artistes
véritable qui ont une grosse ou non pas
top mais une énorme féminité dès qu'on
est face aux halles et héros qui veut
tout de suite faire le brillant sap sap
longue quand une femme parle ça élève ou
alors quand on a un metteur en scène de
talent tout d'un coup l'ambiance est
bonne on a un compliment quand on rend
ton rantissi ya baffie qu'immédiatement
entravent le mouvement baissier gens
refusent devenu roi
justement par rapport aux hommes vous
dites souvent que ce que vous dites est
ce que vous détestez chez les hommes
c'est leur manque de civilité vous avez
dit un jour la chose la pire c'est la
lourdeur la bêtise la vulgarité des
hommes
en volant au volant par exemple ils sont
vulgaires les mecs leur bagnole seller
phallus leur petit zizi faut que ça
grandfonds klaxons ça vrombit là il ya
pas de jean gol bientôt il ya surtout tu
vas tu y ailles non contre la déjantée
du foot mais moi j'étais je vais être
franche je suis quelqu'un qui qui
débutait la télévision et je vous
connaissais pas beaucoup et j'ai été
fasciné par des choses que vous dites
quand vous êtes un taudis d'actes je
trouve que c'est et justement la façon
de vous parler des hommes et dont vous
parlez des fans m'a beaucoup interpellé
allait bien non
je crois que j'avais une ouverture un
sérieux là je crois que vous faites
quand on vous voit sérieusement on voit
on cherche une explication c'est une
sorte de génie c'est vrai que c'est pas
de la flagornerie de vous dire ça toute
façon et vous dites je ne suis pas
intelligente j'ai des intuitions des
parfois des fulgurances comme ça et je
peux sentir à merveille le mouvement
d'une phrase une espèce de dons
et c'est vrai que vous savez non
sérieusement vous savez restituer le le
poids des mots l'essentiel de vous dit
l'essentiel dans le ptc de restituer
vous savez restituer le poids des mots
ça y est c'est ma passion quoi enfin
voila il fait des films il fait des
blagues elle fait de l'intelligence et
du charme vous êtes efficace et très
intelligent et moi mon boulot c'est de
restituer le génie d immense écrivain et
des subventions alors séduit uniquement
de la de l'obsession et de la névrose à
voir ça comme objectif y en a ils
veulent se faire des meufs qui en a ils
veulent avoir des grosses bagnoles et un
équivalent du pognon moi je suis
toujours été et est fasciné par ce que
représentait une phrase n'importe
laquelle une grande phrase quand un
écrivain a une dimension immense tu te
dis comment un acteur ne va pas entraver
la beauté l'innocence de cette phrase
comment il va faire comment il va faire
pour tout détruire comment il va aplatir
là il ya un moyen soit il n'a aps la
tipa il devient un vrai comédien ou soit
il essaye d'être à la hauteur ou la
phrase a été écrite à ce qui est encore
plus étonnant chez vous quand on voit ce
spectacle c'est que vous avez
parfaitement autodidacte
et à l'école ce que certif et vous avez
arrêté très tôt donc à l'âge de 13 ans
et demi après vous êtes tous rattrapés à
quelle époque vous avez tous rattrapés
je suis en train alors contraint il ya
longtemps que les tout rattraper qu'on
annonce est un travail quotidien vous en
êtes encore déverminage là je suis vous
savez malheureusement je suis très
obsessionnel c'est à dire je je
travaille les mêmes textes toujours les
mêmes comme des gammes inlassable
vous avez dit quand j'ai commencé chez
même pas ce que c'était une amibe
enfin parce que ça c'est le programme
secondaire
tout depuis la 6e à la fois à léon 16e
pour savoir ce qu'est ce que c'est une
amie provenant du tout vous n'êtes pas
en sixième mais non j'ai vu chez ge peu
j'ai pas mal appris beaucoup changé
depuis que je suis avec vous mais c'est
juste que qui n'agit qu'il ait appris
grâce à une une fiancée merveilleuse qui
était l'ami d'une guitariste oui
vous avez appris aussi grâce à quelqu'un
mais je vais vous venez chez sa vie par
coeur
bah ouais
y'a un truc encore
il va se passer quelque chose
gachet toujours cru que tu vois pas ce
que sa fille parce que celle ci commence
avec moi
voilà ce que c'est une amie
une amibe blanc bat y en a ici c'est un
animal unicellulaires qui a des poils
ciliées pour se déplacer voilà
maintenant non mais je voulais aller au
bout de l'histoire ce qui est encore
plus étonnant fabrice et que vous avez
jamais eu la vocation vous dites ne sais
même pas ce que c'était la vocation
quand j'étais petit
la vocation c'est un truc qui n'a pas
grand quine et ça veut rien dire c'est
très laid votre interrogation réel mon
interrogation réel c'est savoir quoi
comment quelqu'un qui a commencé dans le
dans onze balade dans rue ramer dans le
quartier de la goutte d'or
en singeant le pape et en faisant la
quête en br faisant semblant de bénir
les gens comment ce petit garçon là qui
s'est arrêtée dès l'école à l'âge de 13
ans 13 ans et demi que sa mère a mis
dans un salon de coiffure
qui s'est retrouvée un jour à angoulême
en se déhanchant dans une boîte de nuit
et qui étaient remarqués par philippe
labro comment ce type qui n'était dingue
que de que deux fringants fête et de
musique
de
type voilà mon interrogation elle est là
qui n'avaient pas la vocation
comment il est devenu fabrice luchini
aujourd'hui il ya des milliers de gens
qui vont le voir sur scène racontée du
baudelaire du rictus d'hugo du nietzsche
et du céline là je ne il ya quelque
chose pour moi qui est de l'ordre du
miracle voilà je sais c'est une couleur
peu pour moi aussi j'aurais pas prévu du
tout les choses comme ça au delà de
réciter ses textes et une grâce
qui vous est tombé dessus que quelqu'un
comme marraine concept de moi je suis
pas responsable de la grâce et qui est
des écrivains géniaux après les
interprètes ils font leur boulot la
grâce c'est qu'il ya des génies c'est ça
la grâce la grâce et qui a des mecs qui
s'appelle baudelaire la fontaine et qui
ont capté avec une certitude une
intuition in ciselure des mots tellement
parfaite des sentiments du coeur humain
et que nous pouvons nous reconnaître
pourquoi la plus belle phrase qui a été
dit sur ce spectacle c'est michel
bouquet et cochet qui l'ont dit michel
bouquet est venu écouter ce spectacle
sur la fontaine et sur céline et il m'a
dit en partant une phrase incroyable qui
est une source d'inspiration il m'a dit
je comprends je comprends l'intérêt
c'est parce que le public sort de ce
spectacle renseigné sur lui même
bon eh bien ces auteurs là où une vertu
il renseigne les êtres humains sur eux
mêmes mais vous qui nous intéresse nous
c'est de voir comment vous avez fait
votre parcours cochet travail le petit
bâton dans la dans la bouche a pas que
ça parce que quand heures de travail des
heures de combien ça parce que quand
vous êtes dans votre boutique dans la
boutique de vos parents tout enfant vous
observez vous vous écoutez le commerce
est une bonne école donc il n'y a pas
que ça il n'y a pas eu cochet
effectivement mais avant cochet du décès
cette façon de transformer ces ses
faiblesses en forces que vous avez eu
depuis depuis toujours ça ça existe
c'est l'héritage de ta mère et ton père
sam c'est que tu l'auras se lancer sur
un truc très pointue de cours d'eau de
quoi on peut se vanter certainement pas
de nos malheureux dont il y en a deux
trois dont chabat il fait des films il a
fait didier cas remarquable il va pas
arriver avec la clope en disant je suis
droit de la piste pour écraser nous y
voilà il ya un grand producteur il y
avait du talent j'ai mis mon énergie
j'étais heureux il peut pas ramener à
son ego l'efficacité de son film moi je
vais quand même pas ramené à mon ego
l'efficacité de ce spectacle ce
spectacle c'est que le public n'aime les
auteurs sont géniaux et moi je suis
comme michel bouquet plus j'avance sur
moi même plus je comprends les
personnages qu'on me donne à jouer - j'y
comprend quelque chose sur moi je crois
que le vrai talent de ce spectacle c'est
l'amour que tu as des mots et la façon
de le vendre et d'expliquer et de
vulgariser je sais pas si le mot va te
plaire de vulgariser des grands auteurs
mais pas de recenser les rentes bulgare
c'est un ressenti de les rendre
accessibles à des profanes et tu vas
donner envie de lire certaines personnes
d'accord mais c'est que ce n'était pas
un projet personnel tu vois pas le matin
que je me sois levé un matin en prenant
pour un jean vilar bis en me disant
fabrice
tu es né pour communiquer la grande
culture française et à destiner 5 tu
seras celui par lequel non pas le
scandale arrive mais par lequel la
littérature ce bo bun la littérature où
elle est la littérature
peinture de marie vous m'avez vous allez
moi ça m'amuse d'être là parce que moi
je prends même je vous avez tout à fait
raison et vous êtes pertinent je dis tu
parce que j'aime revue j'ai préféré dire
tu c'est évident que l'ego modeste est
encore pire que l'ego machin mais dans
l'époque dans laquelle on est à part des
gens qui savent la traduire et la ville
est là et c'est que l'aïe là je vais
faire la fameux le fameux cliché sur moi
il ya une chose sur l'humilité qui est
écrit par nietzsche qui est magnifique
parce que c'est vrai que ça se vend
vache c'est très vendable l'humilité tu
comprend un mec qui arriverait qui
dirait à
ces normes spirituellement
sexuellement je suis une bombe atomique
intellectuellement à par spinoza ya peu
de mecs qui font le poids au niveau du
talent je pense que l'on a dit allen ou
très sincèrement chaplin
chaplin ou 10 à la nema demandeurs sont
un peu des rats côtés de me
présenter mais moi je suis je en plus ça
pourrait être passionnant de parler de
qu'est-ce que ça la modestie tous à la
mode et sculpteur
je suis content que mes malheureux
phrase est une toute petite efficacité
sur votre corps car ce corps sans mon
esprit également mais j'aimerais que ce
soit les deux vous le savez
davantage luchini
j'essaie de me rattraper
donc je ne saurai jamais en fait
on ne sait pas
quand j'étais dans une école de
comptabilité j'étais dans une école de
comptabilité pendant un an on ne parlait
du bilan actif passif il fait ça aussi
bien rue ferdinand flocons dans le
xviiie arrondissement à 14 ans mamie
avenue montaigne dans un salon de
coiffure où on m'a parlé de permanente
des bigoudis de brushing puisque je
commence toujours en rétracter après
jeudi l'ate quand même à
l'infini avec adamo énorme
quand je me suis retrouvé dans les
permanentes et après j'ai passé les
épingles et après les brosses et puis on
m'a dit tu vas accéder à la mèche
on m'a dit oui tu vas prendre une brosse
ronde et on séchoir jeudi mais c'est
merveilleux les plus grands moments de
ma vie j'ai pris la mèche et j'ai
commencé à se chauffer la femme était
hyper heureuse comme ça disait je sens
qu'ils sont lourds puis elle les mettait
ses cheveux et moi je mettais une glace
toujours et tu disais vous êtes contente
de ça et je mettais tous ses cheveux en
avant ce qui fait qu'elle était hyper
heureuse que 7 0 mais quand vous me fait
un brushing sont lourds montrez-moi la
glace derrière là je remettais tout et
elle faisait un mille son lourd là aussi
donc elle était hyper heureuse j'ai
appris le mentir vrai voilà mot sublime
de jouvet le mentir vrai alors quand je
comprenais pas très bien de quoi il
était question d'un permanent je vais
arriver à votre réponse je connais pas
bien la permanence je comprenais pas
bien la comptabilité je ne comprenais
pas bien la colle la couleur quant à
nous est plein de soleil faisait fabrice
du soleil avait du soleil partout à
neige et que c'était la mode de raquel
welch a fêté paralysé
faites moi comme une tigresse
[ __ ] quand je prenais ma proches et ma
brosse sa pige tirait parce que vous
savez dans la coiffure on doit appuyer
sur les racines pour que ça gonfle donc
je tirais pour que soient gonflés par
tech des espèces de tête effrayante
ça m'a beaucoup passionné sauf que je ne
comprenais pas de tout ce dont il était
question après j'ai été dans plein
d'autres endroits et un jour à 23 ans
après avoir fait un film bizarre avec
eric rohmer un grand agent très connus
d'art médias m'a dit c'est un métier
vous avez un certain don bon c'est un
métier je suis rentré chez cochet et là
il s'est passé un truc comme ça me
thérèse d'avila et comme métriques art
cochet a mis en scène à musset il y
avait un acteur qui travaillait et
cochet a dit à l'acteur chaque phrase ce
que ce que devait ce que l'acteur devait
nourrir pour que la phrase prenne sa
dimension et pour la première fois de ma
vie
pour la première brialy j'ai compris de
quoi on parlait c'est comme si j'avais
été autistes
ce pack je vous le fais
j'ai pas je vais pas imiter je ne
comprenais pas et le jour où j'ai
entendu au dedans routier prêtres vont
battant le pays est brûlant la moisson
lescop été braqué au point de tout
puissant et que je voyais cochet qui est
gênant mais pas ton doigt comme ça alors
on dirait les frères ennemis ne met pas
qu'on doit chaque à dire simplement
anciens vainqueurs du monde espagnol que
nous sommes quelle armée avant nous et
il lui il illustrait le mystère du texte
j'ai vu la plus belle des choses comme
je vais j'ai vu un professeur et éclairé
le mystère d'un immense texte ça a été
le plus grand moment de ma vie après il
a mis en scène un feydeau et à partir de
cette seconde là je me suis dit hé bien
il n'y a qu'une chose que je comprends
dans la vie c'est le théâtre le cinéma
des émotions le mystère des hommes et
des femmes et je vais faire ce métier et
coup de bol j'ai fait des trucs ça a été
très dur pendant longtemps jusqu'à les
nuits de la pleine lune ou après je vais
faire de lego puisque on me reproche
d'être humble g j'ai fait du chemin j'ai
fait des films ça ne manque pas des
phrases comme elle en est où la couleur
de bonhomme mouillart
c'est pas des phrases des mots qui te
manque un peu non parce qu on attend d
où la couleur de la muya c'est des
phrases que tu prononcer avant le salon
j'avais pas cette responsabilité
hiérarchique parce que
comme tu l'as dit on déjà est une
nouveau être le roi de la piste non moi
j'étais tout simplement voilà voilà
qui peut dire voilà voilà dans sa
coiffure bah non tu dis mais voila voila
il n'y a pas de cannes ans tu dis voilà
des corps qui prenait les pourboires tu
disais quoi bon aller pour voir ça se
passait comme ça reste est assez
agréable prenez va mener comme ça mais
qui monte quand même qu'il ya des cas
semblables
et elle mettait dans le jean un très
proche du sexe sous la coupe droite et
il y a je me tirais beaucoup ce je vais
vous dire la vérité je me tirais
beaucoup sur la tige parce que je voyais
der dette énorme je peux vous dire
marlène jobert c'est bien par
se faire épiler ah bon oui à la cire
alors on mettait de la cire sur leurs
cuisses
mais moi j'avais des débuts très léger
de culotte blanche très douce
je sortais et alors j'allais dans mon
dans l'endroit où on se détend des et là
j'avais une super coiffeuse qui se
débloquer avec un petit shetland de
l'époque parce que c'était le drogue
stop shetland tout court moi j'espérais
avoir des belles weston donc je mettais
mes pourboire de côté pour acheter des
mocassins à 160 francs à cette époque là
maintenant il faut en 2002 et est
maintenant je vais vous dire la vérité
au niveau financier je suis très bon
parti si vous voulez humainement je suis
moyen frais physiquement assez instable
seulement ce que votre âge on disait
vous n'aviez aucun charisme sex with a
bien joué alors votre âge en disant mon
problème avec toi je sais pas si tu es
homosexuel ou hétérosexuel ou peut-être
rien du tout tu n'as aucun charisme il
l'a dit ah c'est pas pour accabler
rousseau est le mec un peu méchant c'est
plus grands agents tu sais c'est
déprimant 01 43 c'est déprimant quand tu
rentres chez un agent qui disparaît ce
qu'on va faire de toi mon dieu je sais
pas quoi faire
écoute je crois que le problème ça fait
quand même quatre cinq films que tu fais
une faute de mandat il n'y a pas de
demande du tout du tout du tout et du
sexe au cinéma il en faut et je crois
que j'ai compris disette il je pourrai
jamais de prendre dans mon agence parce
qu'on ne sait pas si tu es sexuée
j'étais déprimé alors que je suis devenu
bon bah c'est vrai les hurle je dire sur
le continent américain quand j'arrive
les femmes commencent à mettre leurs
mains près de leur sexe et
[Musique]
sur le tarmac c'est beau très beau nom
mais c'est je me plaisent beaucoup aux
nanas maintenant pas énormément non plus
faut pas croire parce que vous allez y
monte et une face au mas bernard qui dit
parler c'est exagéré donc c'est évident
qu'il ya une brac par mois qui propose
une miette à moitié dans son lycée à
damas ni l'équipe ne dit
donc tous les deux mon avis est tout
prêt non pas de se fermer de se proposer
comme perspective
il propose la botte à lapleau dit écoute
comme ces photos qu'il nous propose mon
lolo un
sac et a raté un tour là à mon avis oui
est ce que vous voulez qu'on fasse une
petite interview à peine down ça veut
dire ça veut dire le plus le mois on va
faire le petit jingle il faut pas bouger
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
est ce que vous préférez chez vous
en vous
physiquement
mais physiquement et dans la tête enfin
bah oui mais alors là on rentre dans le
privé pur porc alors non non c'est des
choses vraiment que je peux pas répondre
qu'est ce que vous préférez ans vous
allez bientôt prendre
et dior ça peut être la main droite on
sait que oui mais ça d'ailleurs rêver
les spectateurs n'ont pas appelé donc
c'est ce que vous détestez chez vous
son album que je déteste chez moi c'est
tout ce qu'on déteste tous c'est-à-dire
l'impuissance de la lâcheté l'incapacité
à et très peu ouvert à des êtres
tout ce qui fait non c'est personnel ou
si c'est non non ça fait 25 ans que je
suis sur un divan avait eu comme dia ou
dit allen savall un tout petit peu mieux
mais je vais pas jusqu'à livrer les bras
se traîne j'aime mon cachemire le plus
grand moment de votre vie jean laurent
cochet quand il a illustré mis en
lumière une phrase mystérieuse de de
feydeau est douce et mais vous pensez
pas que c'est quand même quand labro
vous a trouvé dans ce dans ce boîte de
nuit angoulême est en train de vous
premier moment de ma vie c'est aussi les
premiers flirts une femme de 30 ans
incroyable avec une énorme poitrine avec
un shetland incroyable m'a collé contre
1 c'était 10 kg à bouhrouz beaujolais
s'étaient tenus par bell simon et pol
pacini ils sont très âgés maintenant et
je marchais j'avais quinze ces gens
avaient un jimmy hyper serré puis
j'avais des cars ville mon temps avec
des boucles puis j'étais un petit mec et
je peux très très long web maintenant
j'ai 48 ans donc je suis un peu en fin
de piste à cause de revenir main et non
menama et elle m'a collé contre le mur
et elle m'a embrassée sur la bouche je
crois que c'est le plus beau moment de
ma vie j'ai senti une langue
savait pas s'il fallait bouge où aller
plus loin a été immobilisé et ça c'est
un très grand moment après j'ai mis la
main sur les seins j'ai dit c'est pas
possible
et après
lentement de manière inquiète je suis
descendue vers ce continent noir cette
chose si inquiétante sur lequel sig moon
a tellement travaillé parce que tous les
gens qui frime en disant
c'est comment je la prends moi
j'y crois qu'à moitié
j'y croit qu'à moitié
magalas grand vide et la grande idée
sexuelle c'est que les mecs les mecs
sont totalement terrorisés ça sera un
autre sujet des missions les hommes de
fabrice le pire moment de la paire
moment de ma vie le pire moment de ma
vie
c'est mais c'est devenu un peu solennel
c'est l'ailé les mauvaises les
inquiétudes quand on passe des choses un
peu inquiétante que dans le corps
médical quoi faut être simple m coutu
attend des réponses est entré les pires
moments de ta vie et puis et puis voilà
après il n'y a plus rien ce qui vous
fait le plus rire dans la vie
télé achat
non ça c'est un peu du conformisme
canal+
qu'est ce qui me fait très rire virait
quand il dit jusque leblanc
grand le sol didier didier non c'est pas
du tout je sais qui a rien pour moi dans
le prochain est ce qu'il ya vraiment
m'interroge en fait parce que je suis en
train de me dire oh j'y mets moi aussi
au départ avant les compliments j'avais
pas pensé mais l'on pouvait de fait mais
c'est pourquoi pas ce que j'ai l'air
comme ça parce que bon j'ai été
déstabilisé mais je suis
vraiment prêt parce que j'ai beaucoup
d'admiration pour toi
ils pourraient faire
faire posé plein de choses à rome c'est
gentil tu me donnes un grand rôle qu'en
europe
bah c'est pas le ga tempérament plutôt
anxieux donc à part quand je travaille
je suis plutôt flipper non mais c'est
parce que vous êtes à dépersonnaliser
que vous êtes un grand comédien c'est
parce que vous n'existez pas oui si vous
existiez mais moi je préférais pernaut
le présentateur de 13h et canal je vois
prompteur qu'est ce qu'on a ce re de
midi palavas bon tu vas chez la
crim très jolie lettre quand j'ai fait
une anomalie à pernod qui est un moment
important dans mon existence c'est que
pour moi le jour j'ai rencontré le 13
heures le régional
j'ai vu un grand j'ai vu un homme normal
tout va je pense que si on mettait un un
électro de bonheur entre pernaut le
présentateur du 13 heures que j'aime
beaucoup et mon truc si on pouvait nous
coller quelque chose sur la table ou sur
le tout sur les cuisses et qu'on dise
d'autres bonheurs 12 par exemple sur
pernod ça doit aussi les 8 9 12 14 16
moi c'est plutôt un deux au maximum sur
fun 12 13 mai ça dure une heure quarante
cinq par jour tout le reste du temps je
pense que la vie de pernod d'ailleurs
l'avis de pernod pardonnez moi ça vous
intéresse mais perd nous devant un porno
ça nous intéresse dans une chose très
simple c'est que il m'a dit c'est
hallucinant parce que comment se fait-il
que vous savez comment je rentre chez
moi parce que j'avais parlé qu'en le
voyant au trésor je visualisais ça
rentrait chez lui tu vas avec la voiture
jeu face à face à une peugeot way ou une
renault on épie que sa femme était en
train de finir et puis quelle il
arrivait pernaut qui faisait chérie tu
veux que je mette un peu de biche tu
vois ce que je dirai la femme dit oh
merde tu sais très bien je m'en occupe
jamais allé j'y mets à laraque et ça
c'est un enthousiasme est vital au
nouveau spinosi a pas même nietzsche à
il faut quand même ne pas être dépressif
pour entrer après le boulot et dire à sa
femme je fais un peu de buts et la femme
faut quand même présente rit oui chérie
c'était drôlement les médicaments qui
met la bûche et puis après l'éphémère je
vais garder la bannière il va garder la
bagnole il revient ça c'est un être qui
va bien il a pas les spinoza il n'a pas
lu ni jean vit totalement pernaut j'en
fais pas un cheval de bataille
médiatique
on verra
c'est fait
voici fabrice luchini
labrie chikli bonsoir fera beaucoup du
mail pour vous à quand une nouvelle
prestation de fabrice luchini sur le
plateau de tout le monde en parle par
exemple delphine guillaume de paris me
dis dès qu'il apparaît sur l'écran mon
coeur se serre et mes jambes ses cartes
non mais c'est vrai nom mais
alors donc bonne occasion de vous revoir
à l'occasion de la reprise de l'arrivée
à new york qui donc la partie américaine
du voyage au bout de la nuit de louis
ferdinand céline au théâtre de la gaîté
montparnasse 26 rue de la gaîté qui
avait été joué jusqu'en avril 2001 et
qui reprend maintenant jusqu'à quand
jusqu'en juillet bien vous savez comment
on fait fabrice la publicité
c vous êtes très gracieux ça me fait
plaisir c'est pas comme d'autres connard
bien alors l'arrivée à new york se situe
dans le bouquin en voyage ou les nuits
c'est le troisième il ya la guerre de 14
il ya l'afrique il ya les amériques et
léon juillet cher thierry je fais
l'intégrale l'intégralité le en juillet
à la gaîté montparnasse la période
américaine et l'installation du docteur
destouches à la garenne rend si ces
trois heures vingt de spectacles d'une
prolongation ça va dans les quatre
heures vingt quatre heures alors bon bah
quand on quand on voit le spectacle
effectivement une première première
phrase c'est new york verticale figurez
vous qu'elle était debout leur ville
absolument droite absolument droite new
york c'est une ville debout
mais c'est très bon ça a été écrit en
1928 il faut aller voir fabrice est une
très bonne façon de rentrer dans ces
lignes c'est d'aller voir fabrice
restituer les gibbons marché avec moi
la vidéo de beaumarchés
ya pas mal
description aussi des chiottes de new
york est incroyable c'est comment
toutefois un moment donné le policeman
du milieu de la chaussée poser comme un
encrier nos mythes ce mythe à ça ne me
suspecter d'avoir des drôles de projets
voilà c'était visible ou qu'on se trouve
dès qu'on attire sur soi l'attention des
autorités le mieux de disparaître et en
vitesse pas d'explication au gouffre que
je me dis à droite de mon banc s'ouvre
est précisément un trou large à même le
trottoir dans le genre du métro de chez
nous ce trouble paru propice
une telle beauté ce trouble paru propice
propice
problème
depuis mon jeu comme un tiers du
spectacle un tiers le plus poignant de
ce qui a été écrit à mon avis dont
indépassable un des passages parce
qu'ils exercent une peine pour être
peut-être françois villon
non c'est extraordinaire dans votre
spectacle c'est que vous ne dites pas
céline vous ne lisez pas vous ne récite
épaves le restituer un ceni
d'accord
quand on arrive bien ces heures là en
haut du pont kolenc oui
on aperçoit au delà du grand lac de nuit
qui est sûr le cimetière les plumes hier
les premières lumières de rancy francis
était clichy les premières lumières de
rang si c'est sur l'autre bord rancy
faut faire tout le tour pour y arriver
c'est si loin alors on dirait qu'on fait
le pire de la nuit même tellement il
faut marcher ne pas autour du cimetière
pour arriver aux fortifications et puis
ayant atteint la porte alors comment
voir par là mais moi
j'ai essayé de ferrat une une
intervention du quartier il a un secret
et une pattes bleues bon caulaincourt
18e déjà bon vous êtes du même quartier
de paris sauf que lui laisse deviner
rustinu alain château rouge à l'art
avons bien sûr y habiter là jamais
renier la réunion mais moi je moi j'y
habite ses plus forts voilà vous
restituer céline plutôt que vous le
dites oui il faut ici de restituer alors
la difficulté c'est d'essayer ne pas
restituer les mots ouais ce qu'il faut
essayer de comprendre enfin de
comprendre pas tellement d' eurobonds
c'est essayer d'être en coincidence avec
l'esprit qui a été l'un à l'impulsion
d'une phrase c'est une ambition qui est
énorme qu'est ce qui s'est passé quand
rimbaud a écrit à les retrouver quoi
l'éternité
le mec peut le dire un peu le faire
c'était ton qu'on veut sur ce qu'on peut
dire allez retrouver quoi l'éternité tu
vois on peut tout dire comment il l'a
lui éprouvé c'est un projet bizarre la
restitution
voilà
c'est le problème de l'acteur c'est la
restitution voilà alors souvent vous
reprenez des phrases vous reprenez des
phrases vous reprenez des freins jusqu'à
ce que le public les est bien comprise
je reprends des phrases parce que
d'abord j'y suis pas tout le temps et
j'essaye comme un musicien d'essayer de
retrouver j'ai la chance d'avoir la
liberté de décider de me dire tiens là
j'en ai j'ai chargé et puis c'est
tellement étonnamment beau qu'il faut
pas se laisser aller qu'à l'histoire
vous réagissez comme c'est quelqu'un qui
tous dans la salle par exemple si je
sens que c'est une toux qui n'est pas
affirmative je l'intègre en disant ah là
un problème de tous cette personne donc
au contraire je suis plein d'amour ou
comptera pas plein d'amour si je sens
une toux arrogante la touche et payer
220 balle et je t'emmerde je vais
t'emmerder concepteur là je peux arrêter
puis je peux lui dire c'est embêtant et
des apartés d'aidé incidente pas tout le
temps mais pas tous une fois bouquet
michel l'acteur grands acteurs français
enfin le grand le plus grand acteur
français je vois une pièce de philippe
siens marceau j'essaye de l'intéressé
mais ce qu'il me donne pas du tout de se
sentir sophie marceau pour l'intéressent
félicien marceau c'est un auteur de
théâtre et puis michel bouquet joignent
bien ça s'appelait le
et alors il sortait d'un oeuf et pendant
quelques minutes il ne disait rien tu
sais il était immobile comme ça et le
public est tellement plus habitué à être
très discret dans le théâtre qu'il y en
a qui disait il a vieilli
[Musique]
et qu'il est inapte faire totalement
lutherie raciale que ces soldes touche
pas à mon pote une incarnation lenglen
de tarifs
et de la fête de la musique
non c'était plus un classement vous êtes
un acteur de cinéma très bien payés oui
beaucoup d'argent que vous faites un
film aujourd'hui c'est énorme et vous
êtes là à faire découvrir céline à des
gens dans un théâtre qui est pas très
grand
c'est un non mais c'est quoi c'est un
sacerdoce non
pas pour y être à deauville à saint
tropez à l'île maurice avec des blondes
décolorées des reports et on va avoir
une énorme capacité enfin il faut être
très fort pour savoir être à deauville
où les vacances très chic m'en faut
avoir un état psychique sur deux soit
supérieur à la moyenne moi je trouve que
c'est surtout les gens qui travaillent
pas qui devrait être récompensé parce
qu'il ya un courage ouais c'est un
courage énorme parce que ce
divertissement dont paris pascal doc
ce mécanisme du divertissement dont
parle thomass wehrmacht
vers 9 heures
un autre formidable qui écrit
ddd livre uniquement musicalement tu
connais pas du tout aux masses beernaert
le neveu de wigan stein c'est très beau
c'est sur glenn hall alors est ce que le
jeu de 7 familles l'oeil qui connaît le
jeune gould oui j'ai convenu un allemand
vous connaissez bling
bling gould le plus gros à la liste de
grands pianistes du monde
these pas le cousin barbara gould
je dois imperturbable je continue mon
interview non sérieusement il ya quand
même si c'est un sacerdoce s'annonce a
pleasure d'art oui je serai pas être
capable d'être mais fut un tarp et en ce
doux
pour les séries nip ans et on est rendu
là même lors de 18ème à dater inquiétant
est en kiosque ça m'angoisse je ne
pourrais pas j'ai besoin de travailler
et le métier d'acteur si on n'a pas la
chance d'avoir la scène qui est
l'endroit où on est anobli où on est au
service de quelque chose de sublime je
vois pas qu'est ce qu'on va faire toute
la journée enfin je n'ai pas d'aptitude
est normal dans l'existence sauf que de
me dire le matin je vais essayer de
plaisir dans la cèze c'est un plaisir
d'essayer d'améliorer le morceau comme a
dit guitry la seule chose qui est
formidable dans le métier l'acteur de
théâtre c'est qu'on se dit que demain on
jouera peut-être un tout petit peu mieux
que la veille c'est pas moi c'est de
guitry vous avez rencontré l'oeuvre de
céline dans le quartier des abbesses
auprès d'un prêtre jean claude barreau
jean claude barreau il s'occupait de
l'accueil de marwa abandon il est du
trône le jeu georges lot de baroque et
un petit très beau très beau il ya vento
mot
sublime il ya une sublime moto c'est
encore un ami on a galéré ensemble et le
prêtre des vrais voyous ceux qui tuent
des gens parce que valence le voiture à
la passe que le 18e avant d'être devenu
un endroit branché moi qui ai 50 ans je
peux en parler c'était un endroit
extrêmement difficile les abbesses était
pas du tout un endroit où il ya de la
mode et ça c'était pas la bastille les
années c'était un endroit où en bois
sans magnifique c'est cette merveilleuse
phrase de ses skis doc gynéco qui parle
j'essaie d'un très beau livre qui
s'appelle la maison des morts
alors fabrice quand on vous parle
évidemment des écrits antisémites de
céline vous dites je ne veux pas être
l'avocate céline je défends son style
pas ses idées et ce qui explique
finalement vous dites sont antisémites
insee son dégoût de soi même c'est sa
façon de l'extérioriser voyait les
choses plus riches à dire qu'on était
dit en plus - love qui m'intéresse c'est
les deux premiers livres donc c'est 1932
et 1934 après le céline après à par
ferry pour une autre fois je suis pas
comme certains grands intellectuels qui
est mieux nord d'un château l'ofc a donc
les problèmes politiques sont arrivés
entre je crois que les premiers pamphlet
assassins sont arrivés assassin oui
l'épreuve les reflets oui mais en cause
d d d d d d êtres fade et des
professions de foi des trucs ceci dit la
haine à l'époque d'alain chez céline a
les seins tendus les total et global
alors évidemment elle s'est fixé sur les
juifs et les protestants mais elle est
globale moi mon truc c'est que j'aime le
chef-d'oeuvre j'aime pas l'individu
m'intéresse moyennement dans la mesure
que ce qui me plaît c'est l'effort
littéraire de le vrai fait pour ça qu'on
quand j'étais adolescent à 22 ans quand
j'ai eu le voyage au bout de la nuit
dans les mains et j'ai appris qu'il
n'était pas un mec bien ça a été
tragique geste était dans une sorte de
rab été un peu ingrats mal bien times
des adolescentes voudrez aimé adoré et
tu dis c'est pas possible que ce génie
là a pu être cet homme là donc tu
refuses puis un jour tu lis les livres
du lit et pendant des années tu dis
c'est pas possible d'aimer quelqu'un qui
est comme ça c'est comme une épée un
moment tu pas prêt avec la maturité tu
te dis que l'oeuvre est une chose que
l'individu en est une autre oui vous dit
la littérature n'est pas nécessairement
associée à de nobles sentiments
effectivement si l'on
s'aimait pas lié aux bons sentiments non
ce manuscrit du voyage qui était vendu
11 millions de francs blé entre les
mains quelques heures d'une réunion avec
les frais avec les frais vous voyez des
agriates millions toi non je montais
psychiquement mais j'aurais jamais pu
mon épouse était là j'en ai pas fait
faire le moindre truc elle n'a pas
arrêté de me dire quand ils ont commencé
à monter les halles dizaine bouge pas
fabrice et je les ai eu dans les mains
n'a une journée entière et je vais le
lire à la bibliothèque nationale a été
finalement promener dans les biotech
nationale vous faites en ce moment une
campagne d'information la télévision
pour les économies d'énergie alors 50%
des la consommation d'énergie et
d'émissions de gaz carbonique est due
aux particuliers c'est ce qu'on apprend
dans cette campagne vous faites ça
pourrait l'argent parce que vous croyez
qu'il faut préserver la planète d'abord
faut le faire parce que c'est un projet
qui était bien écrit par un un
publiciste admirable qui s'appelle money
nicolas est
évidemment je l'aurais pas fait
gratuitement parce que je l'aurais moi
bien fait
il faut surtout pas faire les choses
gratuitement parce que c'est ça qui est
merveilleux dans l'argent c'est que ça
enlève le problème de la dette on sait
pourquoi les gens vont voir les top en
ce doux parce qu'il n'ya plus d'affect
ya plus un projet sur toi on it entame
pas puisque tu payes personne n'est lésé
son manque d'amour a dû tout genre ou
d'amour trop c'est sûr mais évidemment
je me suis doc gynéco quand vous avez un
rapport affectif avec une jeune femme
elle peut investir sur vous
progresserez et comment vous vivez le
fait que vous êtes un voleur je largue
sans l'arraché et comment se passe le
problème de votre conscience au niveau
moral tout simple il fume pas ce qui
aurait été vous êtes un moraliste et une
très belle phrase de proue ce que je
garde toutes mes maîtresses
éternellement je vais vous dire un truc
un jour il ya proust qui se promène dans
la rue dans un bois et il monte sur le
sur un arbre et il voit deux jeunes
filles faire l'amour et il monte dans
l'arbre pour observer avec intensité
proust et un moment une des deux jeunes
filles dit tiens avant de jouir je
voudrais mette la photo de mon père et
proust dit cette phrase extraordinaire
comme cette femme devait être moral
comme l'est le laisse là dessus du gant
reste comme ça tu vas rester je t'en
prie tu peux rester comme cette femme
devrait être si canaliser
j'aimerais passer une soirée entière
avec doc gynéco vraiment élaborer sa
petite ud à la jouissance qui me fascine
comment on peut être à ce point libérer
de ce qui nous empêche de vie cette
image de doc gynéco prêt à jouir prêt à
avoir beaucoup de maîtresses d'ayant
aucun problèmes moraux ça c'est une
merveille en
[Applaudissements]
bien interview mensonge fabrice luchini
en fait la russie cnis c'est pas votre
vrai nom votre vrai nom c'est fabrice le
teillac d'argence et ça explique
d'ailleurs beaucoup mieux votre
personnage que votre histoire d'enfance
dans le 18ème arrondissement
mais en fait d'une famille de nobliaux
provinciaux de côté de bordeaux était
ruinée par l'abolition de l'esclavagé
et votre mère était en fait dingue de
théâtre et un jour après la guerre elle
monte à paris
elle va voir louis jouvet sur scène elle
a une aventure avec louis jouvet dont
vous êtes le fruit fabrice luchini ce
qui a été pour moi d'abord un référent
écrasant puisque c'est de toute évidence
rôle de père bah oui c'était
un mec qui a été très influencé par le
living theatre il ya un peu précédé de
montrer sa top de cépie sur le bli pu
c'est un mec qui a été vraiment un mec
un rebelle tu vois un rebelle jouvet ces
jeunes gens n'ont pas bien compris que
je voulais c'était la transgression la
liberté il dit avant avant d'entrer
était docteur un moment l'été fabrique
non mais là tu vas tu n'as pas le droit
de le dire
alors votre enfant c'était assez
solitaire votre père vous aimait pas
parce qu'il savait que vous n'étiez pas
de lui et en fait votre seule obsession
pendant votre enfance et l argent c'est
à dire ce qu'ils procurent surtout les
filles la drogue et pour avoir tous à
vous décider à ce moment-là goûter une
chaîne de salons de coiffure comment
vous est venue cette idée parce que
c'était bien avant mais j'avais un
en-avant maniatis et de sange il y avait
une mode qui s'appelait le brushing et
j'ai aidé grâce à la mise en plis et
grâce à la transgression de la mise en
plis parce que faut pas oublier qu'à
cette époque là la véritable révolution
c'est qu'on a abandonné le rouleau vous
savez doc gynéco que les femmes étaient
des rouleaux avant des rouleaux
chauffants donc c'est le moins cher en
fait qui a fait votre succès c'est le
brushing café un succès c'est une chaîne
de salons de coiffure il révèle dans
toute la france à l'époque ouais pas été
milliardaire à l'âge de 20 ans et
ah oui absolument et gagné par
l'interview fête du cinéma et du théâtre
si vous commencez à vous financez vous
même votre propre carrière oui parce
qu'il y avait un refus villa - de ville
a vu la puissance du pas du père il y
avait un film intègre il a fallu me
faire un prénom ouais et la bombe
faisait pas le talent de père c'est
clair non bon donc vous produisez vous
même toutes sortes de navets à l'écran
de 2 bits sur scène vous en foutez oui
peut vous show un peu me chaut
oui parce que parce que obsédé par
obsédé par le pouvoir financier ouais
c'est ça mais je ne suis pas bon mais
c'est pas grave c'est pas grave j'ai
l'argent je peux me permettre finalement
de de me payer ses films pourris une
sorte de cynisme haineux sur l'humanité
c'est un dégoût total du genre humain
est vacante à un père qui te reconnais
pas
v'nu bon vous avez une limousine avec
les vitres fumées des gardes du corps
pour vous allumez votre cigarette
surtout quand vous trôner dans votre
restaurant ouvert près des champs
elysées chez les riches pourquoi avoir
ouvert ce restaurant est pourquoi
l'avoir appelé comme ça ailleurs chez
les riches c'est un peu bas parce que
jean claude brialy smaïn ont des restos
et je me suis dit pourquoi j'aurais pas
un resto mais aussi quoi vous y dîner
des fois dans ce restaurant je dîne
beaucoup oui ça vous plaise je pratique
la macrobiotique donc il y a deux
sections dans ce restaurant côté il ya
la section très viande et puis il y en a
une ou mange la le régime conseillé par
oshawa un bon cd ya 70% de céréales et
30% de légumes mieux le virage 5 ans de
fois vous savez que le minimum pour la
macrobiotique pour atteindre ce niveau
qui est assis paisiblement sans rien
faire l'herbe croit d'elle-même j'te
l'arpette a6 avant lui plaire assis
paisiblement
sans rien fait
l'herbe croix belle même là me pose tout
seul
fabrice oui vous avez l'intention
d'ouvrir une boîte échangiste au
sous-sol de ce restaurant je fasse un
travail d'acteur énorme
j'ai l'intention d'aller beaucoup plus
loin je pense que je pense qu'il faut
essayer de donner aux gens l'envié de
moins en moins s'investir
de leur faire croire de plus en plus à
cette image du plaisir constant il n'y a
pas de solution ni dans le travail ni
dans la passion la passion sous sas et
intel important dans l'existence et site
est totalement cool parce que quand je
mets ça dans les années 70 tu vas toi tu
ne sais pas tout ça mais à formentera
les gens fumaient d'état rhdp de 17 mais
ce que je veux dire les gens pensent que
les gens pensent que tout est nouveau
mais c'est un jour tu as la chance de
lire les grands textes de cocteau sur le
dérèglement des sens si un jour tu as la
chance de lire rimbaud
vous passez toutes vos vacances en
thaïlande oui mais vous dites c'est ma
façon de participer au développement
économique du pays
tout à fait
alors
contrairement à vous on ne commençait à
boisset moi ce titre et vous ayez
remarqué en dessous les éditions avons
géré pas encore un gadget
il arrête ça m'arrive de ré cela reste
leur seul contre visa mais vous avez
contrairement à doc gynéco donné aucune
liaison fixe
sauf valérie kaprisky
on vous a vue sur le rebord d'arthur à
saint tropez l'été dernier avec valérie
kaprisky il y avait eu 10 derrière lee
barclay ouais il y avait du coeur n'ose
y avait carlo collaro y'avait carlos et
surtout les pousses de carlos avec qui
j'ai commencé dans mon entreprise de
coiffure voix fall et
emmanuel minimes on y vient l'appeler
mimi voilà je les rencontre et au flore
avant-hier soir et vous avez pensé à
épouser valérie kaprisky un moment quand
je les ai vus dans le film sublime
l'année des méduses
j'ai été assez bouleversé oui alors
question de rock c'est plutôt mon
problème c'est tout arrêter à fabrice
luchini de la télé valium
à l'événement il y avait isabelle
maintenant il ya stéphane
bonnat stade laurent baffie parce que
quand même rire autant spontanément je
faire était de maliens vous avez été le
prozac je vais arrêter le petrus les
marlboro reste l'héroïne mais enfin bon
c'est oui mais bon on s'y sent très
rapide vous dites l'hérault c'est la
meilleure parce que c'est la plus chère
non mais c'était la cocaïne en prennent
à une speed riz et internes l'héroïne en
train de lutter
politiquement vous êtes proche des
libéraux ben vous êtes on pourrait dire
machinist votre devis c'est un peu que
les meilleurs gagnent et les autres on
s'en fout ce qui est formidable dans le
courant libéral il n'y a pas de projet
existentielle or il y a juste un
rendement efficace et à une sensation de
liberté y'a pus cet état qui vient
ouvrir les portes pour assister une
sorte de conviction de rohr
responsabiliser l'individu alors que les
tentatives du lendemain qui chante était
toujours certes d'espoir et ont toujours
donné une sorte de gérer facilement oui
c'est que l'enfer est pavé de bonnes
intentions finalement oui je pense que
le courant libéral dont vous avez parlé
à au moins sept vertus c'est de redonner
une impulsion et puis tous ont tellement
sexy tout s'est énervé et aux hommes
politiques sont dans mon envie il
incarne en plus pour finir on va passer
à vos convictions philosophiques très
arrêtée à vous dites je n'existe pas
parce que je n'ai jamais vu oui il y en
a d'autres qui l'ont dit mieux vaut
avoir appelé âgé de 30 ans et
zarathoustra quitta son pays et le lac
de son pays il se leva 1 atteint il dit
au soleil qu'est-ce que tu serais si tu
ne nous avaient pas pour nous éclairer
alors voilà je suis comme toi j'ai
besoin que des mains se tendent et
zarathoustra descendit de la montagne où
il était resté quinze ans pour trouver
la cèze et y rencontre un vieil homme et
le vieil homme a regardé zarathoustra ya
10 mais je reconnais cet homme il y a
quinze ans cet homme a apporté ses
cendres à la montagne tu veux porter
maintenant ta flamme aux hommes ne
connais tu pas le châtiment premier aux
incendies m
écoute bien ne connais tu pas le
châtiment premier aux incendiaires et le
zarathoustra répond mais moi j'aime les
hommes c'est pour ça que je redescend
vers toi tu imagines tu vois la
situation tu la sens là ça va pleurer et
après le vieil homme a dit mais moi
j'aime les hommes en aimant dieu et
comment tu aimes dieu a demandé
nietzsche et ben moi j'aime dieu en
chantant avec les ours et cetera et
cetera tarom ainsi les hutois en son
temps avec les avec les ours et tout
d'un coup ils se sont quittés c'est la
fin du premier chapitre de nietzsche et
tout d'un coup nietzsche c'est un
jaghatu strass est arrêté sur une pierre
et il a dit ce vieil homme ne s'est il
donc pas que dieu est mort je t'embrasse
très très
la paix
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater le in
a l'habitude abonnez vous je m'étais un
peu ce bleu